excusez moi on nous cherche 7 lille où
elle se trouve et un sas et village
d'astérix chercher le véritable village
d'astérix
une idée qui semble complètement
loufoque mais pas pour ces bretons cr
qui est requis c'est tout droit là bas
est requis est un petit village située
tout au nord de la bretagne et dans la
région tout le monde est persuadé que
c'est ici que se déroulent les aventures
d'astérix et obélix le plus fervents
défenseurs de cette thèse le voici
jean pierre allain un irréductible aux
bretons quand j'ai lu le premier astérix
le gaulois
j'ai dit mais c'est bien sûr fait art
qui depuis trente ans jean pierre
décortique les albums un parent pour
rassembler des preuves
c'est devenu une véritable idée fixe
pour nous convaincre
il nous dévoile son principal argument
vous voyez donc que c'est au nord de la
bretagne avec un cap et avec les trois
pierres
trouvez-moi ailleurs un cap avec les
trois pierres à l'ouest c'est indéniable
effectivement c'est assez troublant
les auteurs de la bd se serait donc
inspiré de ce décor et à erquy jean
pierre n'est pas le seul à en être
persuadé fqc le village de saric ça ne
peut pas être ailleurs
oui aucun doute possible nous sommes
absolument tous persuadés que astérix
est bien est né ici
pour tout le village c'est devenu un jeu
résultat les commerçants en rajoute sur
jouent leur rôle mêmes n'hésitent pas à
créer eux mêmes des similitudes avec les
personnages de la célèbre bd et je serai
votre poisson comment ça il est pas
frais mon poisson bien sûr qui effraie
j'arrive même pas l'attraper et regardez
moi ça il brille magnifique célèbre
réplique dendre alphabétique le
poissonnier de la bd à quelques mètres
de là le tailleur de pierre va encore
plus loin il a sculpté un granit géant à
lévis d'obélix le plus connu des
sculpteurs de menhirs heureusement qu'on
a goûté depuis son magique parce que
sinon ça serait impossible
et en parlant de pressions massives et
du peu de potion magique se donne quoi
la portion astérix ou se donne la
portion obélix on l'aura compris même si
les habitants en rajoute un peu au
village nos amis les gaulois font partie
intégrante du folklore local une
véritable attraction pour les touristes
ont des venus ici parce que cette visage
d'astérix et d'obélix
j'ai même amené mon chien s'appelle
idéfix idée fixe comme le chien d'obélix
ici même les touristes sont à fond la
thèse de jean pierre intrigue et a fini
par attirer les télés de toute l'europe
à l'office de tourisme
on est ravis on a reçu radio allemand de
télévision allemandes autrichiennes
française bien sûr on laisse planer le
mystère on aime faire coller la la
réalité et puis là et puis la fiction
imaginée par monsieur des réseaux albert
uderzo et le dessinateur de cette bd
mythique astérix obélix et tous leurs
amis que c'est lui qui les a créés c'est
lui aussi qui a déchiré le fameux
village
alors pour savoir s'il s'est réellement
inspiré d'air qui nous lui avons
simplement posé la question pour eux de
chômeurs ceux qui y croient
sur cela mais on ne le dira pas oui on
dira à personne
un flou artistique qui laisse la porte
ouverte à toutes les hypothèses
du coup d'autres villages viennent jouer
les trublions c'est le cas de perros
guirec à 100 km de là depuis quelques
années gilles le libraire locale affirme
à qui veut l'entendre que le village
d'astérix c'est chez lui
voici à perros guirec le village des
irréductibles gaulois gilles essaie de
trouver lui aussi des points communs
entre son village et celui de la bd mais
ce n'est pas gagné
nous voilà à l'orée de la vallée des
traouiero ce qui est une vallée très
boisé riche en marcassins et ensembliers
donc une espèce de deux réservoirs de
nourriture pour les gaulois que qui
habitait dans la région à l'époque un
peu mince comme argument mais gilles n'a
peur de rien ils n'hésitent pas à
surenchérir celle architecture typique
et petits toits jaunes sont des toits de
chaume
on a un exemple ici on a émis
l'hypothèse que cette chaumière seraient
celles d'assurance tous risques se barde
puisque comme vous savez il a une voix
de crécelle et donc c'est bien qu'il
répète un peu loin du monde comme ça
blague à part la position géographique
et la présence démontré deux gaulois
dans la région pourrait apporter un peu
de crédit aux affirmations de gilles
alors pour en avoir le coeur net nous
sommes retourné voir notre ami ou des
réseaux on a parlé de perros guirec
alors ça ça m'étonnerait que je connais
aussi perd aussi avec da sûr mais jamais
depuis un siècle on puisse revendiquer
2000 à wavre si ce n'est pas perros
guirec c'est donc il s'agit vraiment
d'air qui alors j'avais
tout ça c'est dans l'imaginaire donc il
a pesé des glacis danse étrange je vous
assure que c'était pas dans l'idée ni
lui ni moi même de créer un village qui
soit bien bien bien bien situé sur une
partie de la côte bretonne n'est requis
ni perros guirec donc
ou alors peut être un mélange des deux
mais mieux vaut garder ces révélations
pour nous jean-pierre comme gilles
risquerait de ne pas s'en remettre
[Musique]